November 3rd, 2020, the U S elections.
The controversial era of Donald Trump is coming to an end.
The time has come to take stock.
What have been the key takeaways from the administration of the 45th president
of the United States of America?
Yeah.
Difference in this video,
we're going to examine and analyze how Donald Trump's term,
as head of the United States has been. This video is neither for,
nor against president Donald J. Trump.
No many of you will see it and will agree with the results or this will surely
not many of you will think that we have left things out or that we've been too
hard or equally too complimentary. But in all honesty,
I think that what we're going to see is a good approximation of what the Trump
administration has been beyond the marketing scandals and political folk law.
And yes, we have probably left a lot out,
but we have had to select and prioritize.
So I encourage you to let us know in the comments,
if you think there is something missing or left out and to open a debate that
said difference that start with what the 45th president of the United States,
Donald John Trump always considered to be his number one priority. After all,
we are talking about a president who came to the oval office,
boasting of his business management skills. So we have no choice,
but to start exactly.
And built the greatest economy in the history of the world.
And now we are very simply, we're doing it again. And we're on track to have,
as I said, the best year we've ever had next year, you just had the best.
It's the economy.
Election campaigns are the times when politicians sell us all kinds of promises,
less taxes, more vacations, more roads, better democracy,
the best education in the world, better sports facilities, whatever.
In that way, elections become a kind of bizarre,
a Turkish Souk where politicians try to win our votes with grand promises,
Promises as lofty and bombastic in the run-up to the election.
As they usually are insipid. When the elected finally comes to power,
that's something I'm sure. And I mean,
absolutely certain that we're all used to by now.
Let's just say it's part of the show. However, friends in 2016,
Donald Trump went much further. It was an ode to the imagination.
You don't believe me.
How about I remind you, just check it out.
The 2016 election campaign, Donald Trump really put his foot down.
He said over and over again,
that his arrival in the oval office would mean that for the first time United
States would be run professionally by an experienced businessman.
Something that would obviously have results.
Donald Trump pledged to change the United States forever. For example,
the 45th president promised that he would multiply economic growth to between
four and 6% annually.
Something that he would achieve through deep tax cuts and a new trade policy.
In fact, following the same line,
the president also committed himself to ending the enormous trade deficit.
That according to him was a burden on the us economy and that's not all,
he also gave his word that he would manage to balance the public accounts and
even better that his policies would make it possible to pay off the entire
federal public debt.
That's more than $19 trillion in just eight years with these changes,
the American people would enjoy a prosperity, never seen.
But remember.
These promises are not ours, but president Trump's of course, four years later,
we can say that what has happened has been very different even without the SARS
coronavirus.
Pandemic
beyond all the Mark.
Thing that has been poured on Donald Trump's alleged economic miracle.
Perhaps we should be asking what other real numbers that his administration has
achieved. Well, it must be said that the first years were not bad,
but not particularly great either now. I'm sorry, but this is not an opinion.
It's just the numbers. Do you want specific data? Well,
let's take a look during the first three years of the Trump administration
employment growth was lower than the second term of the Obama administration.
Meanwhile, the average economic growth was higher,
but very similar wages also grew more. That's true, but very slightly,
just two tenths of a percent more each year from an average of 1% during the
entire bomber era to one of 1.2% during the Trump era.
And on the flip side,
foreign investment fell in 2019 to its lowest level since 2006
friends take note, because this is important. This scenario,
all these results were also baked in an enormous increase in public spending and
the monetary expansion policy of the federal reserve. Take a look at this chart.
For example.
The Trump administration in just three budgets,
public spending has skyrocketed not counting coronavirus rescue packages by
around 20%. This represents an annual increase of more than 6%. In other words,
public spending under Trump has grown three times more than the national
economy. And of course, if you also lower your taxes,
what you find is a gaping hole.
And that's exactly what has happened in spite of the economy growing by more
than 2% and the nation being practically in full employment,
the federal public deficit in 2016 was almost
$980 billion. That's 4.5% of the GDP.
And that's not all for this year, even without the coronavirus,
a deficit of almost 5% was projected 5% with the economy growing and operating
at full employment. That's crazy. So imagine where these figures would go in.
I don't know, in a crisis, well, what the heck? It's 2020 and we're already.
You know what?
The federal government is expected to close 2020 with a public deficit of over
17%. Yes, that's right. 17%. You're not mistaken.
And we haven't misplaced any decimal points, 17%. And this,
this is what explains why the public debt has not only not been repaid,
but has actually skyrocketed
At Donald Trump's first three years at the helm of the country.
Public debt grew by more than $3 trillion. Yes,
that's trillions with a T of dollars.
If we add that to the impact of the Corona virus by mid 2020,
it had passed the $6 trillion Mark to give you an idea.
This is more than the entire GDP of Japan or practically the total of the GDP of
Germany and France.
Reduce our 18 trillion in debt. Because believe me,
we're in a bubble,
we have artificially low interest rates be careful of a bubble.
Cause what you've seen in the past might be small potatoes compared to what
happened. So be very, very careful.
My friends are the numbers. Of course,
these are facts that have been largely camouflaged by what has been a huge
marketing campaign spurred on by statements like this.
We made and brought this country to the greatest point in its history.
We never had an economy like we had, we never had numbers like it.
We're going to have them again, Donald Trump.
Well.
By now we all know Trump and his usual relationship with the truth that said his
government did have some significant successes with its economic policy.
During this time there was for example,
the tax cuts and jobs act that's the administration pushed through and managed
to pass at the end of 2017.
The biggest tax reform in 30 years got the biggest tax cut.
Jake.
Are talking about the law. That's largely reduced personal income, taxed,
encouraged tax competition between States and above all reduced corporate income
tax by establishing a kind of flat tax. In addition, this is one of the keys.
It changed the scope of this tax, which is no longer worldwide. In other words,
American companies no longer have to pay in full for the profits they make.
For example, in Europe where they have obviously already paid their taxes.
The fact is that these measures allowed for an increase in corporate profits and
therefore boosted the strength of North American companies that competitiveness
and their stock market value.
This is one of the factors that has contributed to the good performance of the
North American stock market over the last few years,
Of course,
what Trump forgot as we have already seen was to adjust public spending as well,
and obviously less taxes and more public spending.
It's a combination that is not usually very advisable in any case,
this tax reform had a reasonably good impact.
So this is what we have now. This is where it would work.
Another area where we can say that Trump has had some success has been in
limiting the expansion of federal regulations. As you can see,
as soon as he came to power on January 30th, 2017, president Trump,
executive order one, three seven, seven,
one ordering the elimination of two existing regulations for every new
regulation that was approved.
And.
Although in the end it didn't work exactly like that.
It is true that during his mandate,
the creation of new federal regulations has been contained.
One way to look at it is to look at the number of pages of the code of federal
regulations that each year codifies existing federal regulations.
Well notice how during the last few years,
the number of pages of this code has remained relatively stable.
Of course,
less regulation is often something that makes life easier for businesses,
especially small businesses.
And it's not that Trump has reduced the number of federal regulations,
but at least they haven't continued to multiply,
but it's clear that despite these achievements, there were also great failures,
Greece, for example, the case of the trade war.
One of the key policies of this administration in less than three years since
its launch in early 2018, Trump has almost turned global trade upside down.
Suddenly he launched into an entire trade war with China and also with allied
countries, Canada, Mexico, South Korea, the European powers, et cetera,
et cetera. And this has been a huge failure,
not only because it undermined their competitiveness of many us companies that
now have had to pay lots of tariffs on their purchases,
but also because it has not fulfilled its essential purpose to reduce the trade
deficit, which in fact.
It's at a maximum October 6th,
2020 U S trade deficit jumps to largest and 14 years in August
writers.
It's apart from the fact that tariffs are costing American citizens and
businesses tens and tens of billions each year, to give you an idea,
Trump has more than doubled the average tariff on all us exports equivalent to
one of the largest tax increases since 1940 and offsetting much of the 2017 tax
reduction. Yes, president Trump doesn't usually count that,
but the accounts are the accounts and that's not the end of it.
Tariffs have caused other countries to take reciprocal actions. So that,
for example,
the figures of Chinese purchases of products manufactured in the United States
is now lower than before the trade war. Again,
many American companies are facing cumbersome bureaucracy and higher costs while
foreign investment in the United States has plummeted to its lowest level since
2006.
Yeah.
Um, a phenomenal success because by the time of the 2020 election in the United
States, there were fewer industrial jobs.
And when Trump came to the white house and take notes,
because this is not over yet,
The latest country in the spotlight is Vietnam. On October, the second 2020,
the department of commerce launched an investigation into alleged unfair
competition that may result in new tariffs. And here we go again, by the way,
do you know how the president is fixing many of the messes that have been
created by these policies? Well, by means of subsidies. Yes.
That's what I said with substance.
May 23rd, 2019 Trump,
his new $16 billion aid package for American farmers hit in trade war,
Washington, post friends.
Do all these results that we've seen so far.
We should add the pressure on the federal reserve to devalue the dollar and
increase its policy of hitting the money machine,
which we already talked about in a video that'll link for you.
I think the fed is out of control. I think what they're doing is wrong.
All of the governments abysmal response to the Corona virus pandemic in the end
in economic matters, Trump's term in office has had some high points. Yes,
but in general, he leaves the country much more indebted,
more close to global markets.
And now thanks to the effects of the coronavirus with fewer jobs and many more
unemployed. And when he came to power and this light,
we can almost say that Trump has been a good example in the United States of
what we would call historical Peronism and Nope, I haven't gone crazy. Not yet.
You have the data and the policies that have been put in place in front of you.
Trump has blown up many historically basic fundamentals of the Republican party,
but friends, of course,
the Trump legislator has not limited itself exclusively to the economic arena.
Listen up.
[Inaudible] a world of fists, flags and steel.
On the question of foreign policy.
Trump's mandate has been anything but quiet from poor relations with Western
leaders to surprise and closeness to many or authoritarian leaders or directly
objects dictators, such as Kim Jong UN of course Trump's term has broken many,
many molds,
but this time we will focus exclusively on the many pros and cons of what has
been perhaps the most unpredictable foreign policy in a long time and friends.
It starts positively because the first thing we could say is that Trump has
become the first us president, not to declare war since 1980.
And that's definitely a good thing.
[Inaudible].
But that is not, of course is only achievement.
This administration has achieved milestones as important as the Abraham Accords,
a historic agreement in which the United States played an important role.
And for which the United Arab Emirates has formally recognized the state of
Israel, a recognition, which Bahrain has since made as well,
and which will probably lead to the rest of the Arab countries,
such as Kuwait and Saudi Arabia following the same path in the near future,
we are talking about the full normalization of relations between Arab countries.
Is right.
The strength of Trump's foreign policy has been, for example,
the return to the policy of deterrence with Iran following the early 20,
20 execution of general Soleimani, the powerful head of the elite Coots forces.
He was one of the heavyweights of Iran's theoretic regime to Trump's credit are
also the defeat of ISIS with the execution of the leader of the caliphate Abu
Bakr al-Baghdadi or his support for Taiwan. Because my friends,
this administration has been particularly close to this besieged Island that we
covered very recently on visual politic. And finally,
there's the peace agreement in Afghanistan or rather the U S withdrawal because
of the defacto agreement gives the Taliban back all of its influence. Of course,
in this case, to be fair,
it is not clear that there was actually any other possible alternative,
but wait a moment, because along with all these successes,
we also find great failures and among them the most important,
without a doubt has to be China.
[Inaudible].
After his arrival in the white house,
Donald Trump launched a kind of cold war against the Asian giant and so far,
well, he's not winning it.
The Chinese government of judging ping is spreading its tentacles,
like never before Africa,
central Asia and even countries of the former Yugoslavia are examples of
territories where China's influence is even more significant than that of the
United States. And not only that,
the modernization of the people's liberation army has made the entire East Asian
region red hot To make matters. Worse.
XE Jingping has debts to put a defacto,
enter the regime of freedom in Hong Kong,
without Washington being able to do anything about it.
It's a far cry from Ronald Reagan's tear down this wall in West Berlin.
Mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall.
Instead we have moved onto the most absolute inaction in the case of Hong Kong,
which until now was one of the freest places on earth.
Asia may seem far away to us,
but think about what this means in what is already demographically and
economically the most important region in the world. Friends,
this inaction was partly due to the fact that all the cartridges had already
been spent in the trade war.
So now the free world is left with tariffs without Hong Kong. And with China,
that is more expansionist.
Then ever. What was the name of that book that he wrote? You know,
the art of the deal.
With respect to such delicate issues as North Korea, Ukraine, or Venezuela,
the administration's achievements have been practically nil. In fact,
we now know that we will have to get used to the idea of a permanently nuclear
North Korea. And if we add to all of this,
the strained relations with many of the historical allies,
the president's trade policy,
which brought the United States out of the biggest free trade agreement in
history, something that Gigi ping,
Shirley celebrated Trump's portrayal of the Kurtz,
his role in feeding the confrontations with Qatar or his inability to hold Saudi
Arabia accountable for the murder of Washington post journalist and columnist,
Jamal Khashoggi. What we have is a real mixture of hits and misses.
On the one hand.
The agreement between Israel and the Arab countries has been a historical event.
And the fact that the United States is involved in fewer Wars is undoubtedly
good news for the United States. But on the other hand,
Trump leaves us with a less open world with a new cold war,
potentially underweight,
for which we may be under prepared and many tyrants running around with a sense
of total impunity. Those are the dark sides, okay.
He's legacy
from the wall to justice and a pandemic well.
Internal policy level. We could say many things,
but I think there are three issues that stand out in their own right immigration
justice and the Corona virus. As far as this healthcare reform plan goes well,
that's to say, it's neither here nor there,
despite all the times it's been promised friends.
If Trump has had one obsession,
it has been the border wall and reducing immigration, all members.
[Inaudible].
The one hand, the war has been a huge failure.
Trump promised it both actively and passively,
but four years later there has been hardly any progress. In fact,
despite all the efforts only 480 kilometers of war has been built of which
420 kilometers by the way are not new construction,
but rather repairs to existing structures. In other words, the Trump wall,
the new Trump wall after four years of promises amounts to a 60 kilometer
extension along the border of more than 3000 kilometers. And of course,
Mexico has not paid a single.
Of course.
That hasn't been their only policy on immigration
Since taking office.
The Trump administration has taken over 400 executive actions on immigration.
His obsession has even extended to H one B visas,
which are grantees to high-level professionals, such as mathematicians,
computer scientists and engineers. Since Trump came to power,
the percentage of rejected applications.
Triple top CEO's denounced Trump immigration policy is threats to U S
economy. The New York times.
We are talking about highly qualified professionals who are key to the
competitiveness of American companies.
And this is certainly one of the reasons why support for Biden is so high in
Silicon Valley.
Perhaps the only thing his administration has achieved in the area of
immigration is that Mexico has stopped a good deal of the migratory flows from
central America that had made him so unhappy.
Comfortable.
On the other hand, where he has reaped,
great triumphs has been in the area of justice in 2018.
And after a bipartisan agreement, he signs the first step act, a law that is,
and as its name indicates a first step towards reforming the judicial system and
giving a greater role to rehabilitation and reinsertion policies.
He has also succeeded in placing thanks to the Republican majority in the
Senate, three conservative judges on the Supreme court,
which presumably guarantees a conservative majority for me.
Yes.
This has enormous influence on us policy. And finally, the failure,
the great thing.
Galia.
Perhaps my friends,
the greatest failure of his entire presidential term has been the way in which
this administration has dealt with the pandemic as evidenced in recordings with
Bob Woodward. Trump knew very early what we were up against,
but he didn't do anything. Well, not only did he not do anything,
but he tried to downplay the seriousness of it and that my friends has come a
very high cost to American society, more than
235,000 deaths at the time of making this video,
we've barely 4% of the world's population.
The United States accounts for around 20% of all recorded deaths.
And of course a huge economic crisis.
Well friends, we may have left out many things,
including impeachment proceedings, but what we have selected,
we believe to be the main markers of the Trump era with its high points and its
low points.
What seems clear in any case is that the supposed economic miracle promoted by
the president simply never existed.
The time has come to ask whether so much tension,
so many confrontations and so many threats have been worthwhile,
but now it's your turn. What do you think of the Trump era so far?
What do you think we have failed to comment on leave us your response in the
comments and let's open up a debate. So I really hope you've enjoyed this video.
Please hit, like if you did, and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
It provided the vocals in this episode that were not mine. Also.
This channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
And learn more about politics and world affairs.
And here's some more of my lovely voice. Um,
check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play or your
favorite pod catcher.